and some breaking news on this story now
the metropolitan police commissioner
christopher dick has announced a review
into
professional standards and internal
culture within the metropolitan police
writing in the evening standard she said
within a week i hope to announce a high
profile figure will be appointed to lead
a review of our professional standards
and internal culture they will look at
our training leadership processes
systems and standards of behavior and
examine cases where officers have let
the public down this person will also
work alongside me challenging my senior
team and our leadership on standards
corruption sexual misconduct and how the
met responds when things go wrong she
wrote that every single one of us in the
met realize that it will take time to
rebuild your trust my pledge to you is
that i will do all i can to improve
women's safety and reduce the fear of
violence that breaking news there a
review of professional standards and
culture in the metropolitan police
announced by the met police commissioner
at democracy dick